all elections important
we know in our bones this one is more
consequential
this is the most important election in
the history of our country
[Music]
from bloomberg quick take i'm madison
mills and on today's episode of the most
important election ever
we're digging into how coveted 19 could
impact the presidential election
we'll also talk through how unemployment
and millions of uninsured americans
have revealed cracks in our health care
system that have been there for years or
centuries
and joining us to unpack all of this and
more is riley griffin a bloomberg news
reporter
and dr lisa cooper from the john hopkins
bloomberg school of public health thank
you both so much for joining us
uh riley i want to dig right into it
because we don't have a ton of time and
starting with you
can you talk about how the pandemic
might influence the election
i know you've done a lot of reporting on
covent voters and their thoughts
absolutely we dove into this very
question in a recent
business week issue that explored
different voter sentiment
the task i had as a pharmaceutical
reporter brought our health care
reporter
was to gauge that what will this mean
how will the
trump administration's handling of the
pandemic actually impact voter sentiment
you know we we looked at polling and
research firms and actually found
that though the pandemic initially
boosted trump's approval rating
as cases and death mount recently
reached 200 000 deaths from the us
his approval rating has continued to
fall
and in particular it's mobilized two
cohorts of voters
one republicans for whom the handling of
the pandemic was really the last
draw in their appreciation of the trump
administration
and also what we call low-propensity
democrats and independent voters who may
not have voted in the 2016 election
and have been disillusioned by the
candidates that have been presented to
them
in recent years but now feel like they
must engage
politically and differently and so those
are the two cohorts that we're looking
to um as a news organization but also
those who i had the opportunity to speak
with for that
this week um some of those were
republicans who have never before voted
for a democrat
and others were democrats and
independents who didn't vote for hillary
clinton
i think what was so jarring madison was
that all these corona voters
came to their understanding of this 2020
u.s presidential election um for
different reasons you had mothers were
frustrated to be
in college tuition fee kids who were
taking classes from home
you had family members who had lost
loved ones due to it
the handling of the chronovirus pandemic
may affect people in different ways but
ultimately
um for these two cohorts it's trending
for
president and riley you mentioned
the impact of some of the economic
factors that have
been really pronounced during covid um
so going to you dr cooper you've done a
lot of work in health disparities in the
u.s
can you just talk through what some of
those disparities look like and
how they might influence voters
decisions on election day
right well we've seen people from
communities of color
african americans hispanics also native
americans
who have really been impacted by coven
19
disproportionately they've had higher
rates of infections
higher rates of hospitalizations and
deaths up to
three times higher than whites so we
know that those
groups have been really um experiencing
a lot of
illness we also know that it's had a
very harsh
impact on the economics a lot of
frontline workers are over represented
among ethnic minorities people of color
people have been in jobs that don't pay
benefits
oftentimes uh and often are in our
hourly workers
and have lost their jobs so it's it's
been
a financial as well as a health impact
and then you add to that sort of all the
racial unrest and the violence
perpetrated against people of color by
the police at this time and it's really
had and i would say an effect also on
the mental health of
these groups and dr cooper sticking with
you um when you
talk about some of these issues it does
make me think about vaccine hesitancy
can you talk through how these
communities specifically might be
impacted by that yeah so you know
a lot of these communities have have
experienced
racism and discrimination for a long
time
there's a history of like
health care inequities so people have
experienced
lack of opportunities to access and and
obtain high quality health care
um we know that there are stories such
as this
tuskegee syphilis experiment that many
people are aware of where
african-american men were untreated for
syphilis
for many years even after the treatment
penicillin became available in that
study
we know about the story of mrs henrietta
lacks who had her cells
taken without her consent or knowledge
and
and her family just learned about it
many decades later
so we know that there's a reason why
african americans and
other people of color may mistrust the
health care system as well as mistrust
science and
so it's understandable that people might
be concerned
that they are going to be either
experimented upon or there's going to be
some harm that will come to them
through this vaccine and also concerns
that people
the broader scientific community or
politicians might be using this
to their own benefit and so you know um
scientists and public health
professionals are going to have to
really work hard
to communicate with those communities
use trusted members of those communities
to really
communicate about the safety of the
vaccine the tests that are being done to
assure
that people will be protected against
any harm from taking it and that it will
be
made available and effective for
everyone and not just for
a certain group of people and going to
you for a moment riley can you talk
about what
the federal government uh is planning to
do
or could do to kind of address some of
those concerns that dr cooper explained
absolutely well to take you back a
moment we've got about 190 different
experimental vaccines in development
according to the world communication
forty of which
has been trialed and four here in the us
have
um particularly important they are
reaching a point in their late stage
studies
that may soon reach that data some of
those names may be familiar
familiar to our listeners and that
includes moderna that include
astrazeneca and oxford that includes
pfizer and bioentech and more recently
johnson and john
and the us government has put together a
cohort called operation warp speed that
is intended to aid those development up
manufacturing distribution and so forth
but that typically take years to develop
and we're trying to do this
in in a matter of months and that has
caused quite a bit of concern
simultaneously you've had a number of
remarks
within the trump administration that
have been fairly contentious
trump more recently called the fda
partaking in deep state activity to slow
down the approval process
of that so there's been a lot of
heightened
political debate surrounding the vaccine
itself and that's fairly impressive
to talk about drugs and vaccines in this
political especially
in the hopes of seeing a vaccine come to
market
for the election around the time of the
election
what the government is doing to
alleviate some facts
as it's disease as we've heard from
general jerome adam is turned to
celebrities and trusted community
officials
we will only approve exactly
an effect and that we're not cutting
corners here though we might be
expediting the process
that u.s regulators will only approve
push forward of that if it confirms
safety and i i suppose this is a
question for
both of you but how do all of these
concerns and just
the rush surrounding the vaccine impact
the voter on election day
um it's literally called operation warp
speed like you said riley so
i'm wondering in the minds of voters who
are already experiencing the vaccine
hesitancy
that you mentioned dr cooper uh how does
that
influence their vote
i personally think a lot of this is
going to come down to what data we see
read out this coming october
um spicer and his partner bio and tech
have
said that they could have late stage
data
that could point to whether or not they
should emergency use authorization
by the end of the month and that is sued
and we will know
you know potentially whether the company
could get an emergency use authorization
by that point
but it's also highly possible that we
don't see a vac income
and many health experts have said
possible that some of these concerns are
alleviated
if we don't actually see a vacuum come
to market before the election that
folks might not feel as though the
political dynamics
are as involved if the approval comes
further down the line dr cooper do you
have anything to add to that
sure yeah i i actually have uh been
pretty
uh involved in some of the work that's
going on with the vaccine development
and scientific monitoring of the safety
of these studies and um you know to be
honest with you i don't really see
a vaccine being available before the
election
um just because even though we're
enrolling patients very rapidly
their concerns about making sure we have
adequate numbers of patients in
different
age groups for example and in uh
different racial and ethnic groups and a
good balance of men
and women uh people with certain chronic
conditions we want to
over uh enroll people who are at higher
risk for
uh covet 19 because we think they are
the ones that would be most likely to
benefit the most from the vaccine
and so you know i think that is going to
take
several more weeks if not months because
we really do have to look very carefully
for any kinds of
adverse events that might happen you
know things that might um
indicate that there's uh that the
vaccine could be
not safe for certain groups of people
and so scientists are being very careful
about this
uh on the one hand we know it's
important to release the vaccine but we
know it's even more important to get it
right
so honestly even though it's warp speed
and
and a lot of the companies are moving
very rapidly there are a lot of safety
mechanisms in place and the nih has also
launched a new initiative
called um the community engagement
alliance against covet 19
and that is a an effort that will be
across the country
uh several states that are being hard
hit by covet 19
right now have been targeted um to be
sites where there will be extensive
efforts to engage with community
organizations community groups community
leaders
from communities of color to better
inform them about the vaccine
and to you know basically and engage
them more in in the research
dr cooper staying with you um can you
just tell us a bit about
we we've talked about vaccines but also
treatments and we've seen some federal
emergency use
authorizations issued um should voters
be concerned about
those treatments getting pushed forward
too quickly as well well
you know i you know i'd say scientists
are not politicians
and we are not willing to put our
integrity on the line
uh because of any political agenda so
i would say that the public should feel
comfortable
and confident of course everyone needs
to be well informed ask as many
questions as you need to
speak with your primary care or your
other physicians to get their opinions
as well
but we as from the scientific community
i can say are not rushing
towards anything we are working very
hard and many of these studies have been
in the works for many
years uh similar studies and we're using
methods that have been used in
other vaccine trials and other drug
trials for example
we know that ram desevere was a drug
that was used
to try to combat ebola and now that's a
drug that has been shown to be safe
so now it's being tested to see whether
it'll be effective against covet 19
and we know about the convalescent serum
trials as well so i
i don't think that people should be
overly worried scientists are not going
to rush this we don't have
any other agenda other than to get this
right and to and to do it in a way that
is safe for our patients and for our
communities
and riley hopping over to you what are
some solutions that the trump
administration is presenting beyond a
vaccine and these authorizations we've
talked about
uh that he's trying to push forward to
influence the health care system before
november third and hopefully get voters
on his side for the election
before pivoting to that question i do
want to add to what dr
cooper did so
but vaccine makers themselves have made
that they're not going to present data
feel fully confident
in that and that's a really important
point you're not
only getting assurances that are hoping
to bolster trust in communities
especially communities of color from
scientists
and health authorities but you're also
getting them from the pharmaceutical
industry as well
as for what trump is trying to do with
his broader health care agenda
if you turn back to july he um you know
put in place four different executive
aimed at lowering drug costs some of
these are still in the rule making state
not necessarily gone back i haven't seen
patients for example reap the benefits
of bucket costs
but that would certainly be a
next step should he be elected would be
furthering
those executive orders something we saw
a bit more recently
was trump um sign an order that would
just
200 discount cards would be sent to 33
million american
um seniors to help them with their out
of pocket
we don't quite yet know where the
funding for that is coming from
entirely um the trump administration's
of the parts will go out with
weeks possibly before the election but
not all before the election
and so some of these other points on
drug pricing
large not just over 19 vaccines and
therapeutics
are also going to come
and dr cooper i'm curious from a health
care perspective
what do you or or health care
professionals more broadly
wish that both biden and trump would
include in their health care plans to
keep americans healthy
right well my hope is that that the
affordable care act will be preserved
i i think that taking that away will
strip away so many people of health
insurance coverage
particularly those who have pre-existing
conditions so i would really like to see
the affordable care act not get stripped
away
i also like the idea that joe biden
has mentioned including a public option
in his plan i think that that would make
health care
more affordable for many people who have
incurred higher premiums
because of you know sort of the lack of
the individual mandate being enforced
and i know that that is something that's
that's now being sort of um looked at
you know by
um our current administration is trying
to sort of strip away
uh some of the as particularly the
individual mandate piece which is what
makes the plan work essentially if
everyone sort of pays into it
and gets coverage then that provides the
support
um you know for people who actually
can't afford
to pay for health insurance themselves
and it allows the states to be able to
expand medicaid
so i would really like to see the
affordable care act stay in place
i would like to see a public option so
that people have more
affordable options and i'd like to see
the expansion of medicaid
and as well as you know support to
continue to go to community health
centers and to primary care
uh prevention and public health efforts
and a final question for both of you
before we wrap uh is just
why is this such an important election
why do you feel that this election
is potentially the most important
election ever
oh so i guess you want me to go first
well
i mean i think this is so important i
think health is um
you know a basic human right and right
now
our health is standing in the way of
everything in this country our economy
has
virtually you know been stopped because
of this pandemic i think we need
a very strong focus on our public health
infrastructure and protecting
our basic social services that people
need in times of crisis and i think
that's a role important role that
government plays
and um and i think this is a time for
people to really look at policy makers
who will support policies that
you know um lift everyone up that give
everyone
opportunities to have health to have a
good job
uh to be able to afford a good education
um and and child care and i think that
you know we need to really look
carefully as
at who is supporting which policies and
not just
what um they're saying or promising
about where
um are the investments really going and
um
are the actions actually following uh
what the words are so i think
it's more important than ever because
this is the largest
crisis that we have faced probably in
i don't know this is the first of all
the largest pandemic in 100 years and
we've got now a whole series of
racial um you know tensions and
economic problems we have this crisis is
a global crisis and we are no longer in
a position
to be a leader because of how poorly we
have handled this
to follow on dr cooper's remark
you know there's nothing more personal
to the american voter than their health
drug policy impact every single one of
us
um and and so this was important
beforehand but now
we are in the greatest health crisis of
our lifetime
and so i think you know this is not
something that has an end date
like into even with a vacuum coming to
market
how long will immunity last how will
people get portable
and accessible access to those vaccines
and therapeutics
what does this mean for economic policy
to come and definitely become it it
touches
every part of our specificity and with
200 000 deaths now having mounted in the
united states i think people are going
to want to know what
we've got our first debate tonight um
and joe biden
will be speaking with one another
and to the american people laying out
their health care agendas
so let's be watching tonight let's hear
those promises the claims those remarks
the reflections on the
car and make sure we're following it as
people
dr cooper and riley griffin thank you so
much for joining us and making the time
this morning uh and for all of you
watching you can continue to follow our
coverage on covet 19 and the election on
all social platforms at bloomberg quick
take
and thank you so much for joining us
today thank you
thank you